lives brought to a standstill in
turkey's largest city
flashflows created by heavy downpours
has catered through the streets
istanbul's most populated district
essential was among the worst affected
low lying and with poor drainage many of
its roads and some residential areas
were flooded those less affected
struggle to clean up their homes
what am i gonna do it's enough this is
my house i lived there when will this
end enough is enough
despite forecast of heavy downpours many
people say little had been done to stop
the floods in many parts of the city
drivers were left to commit on roads
that looked like lakes
it is the third time this summer that
torrential rains have flooded istanbul
the city's population has grown nearly
threefold in the last three decades but
critics say planning and infrastructure
have failed to keep up
europe's largest city has been hit by
heavy rains once again the government
says that the municipality of istanbul
that's controlled by the opposition
didn't take proper measures despite
warnings but the opposition says the
previous mayors from the ruling party
didn't invest in modernizing the city's
infrastructure many of those affected
say the blame game must end and
solutions be found
al jazeera istanbul